after years of waiting Grand Theft Auto
fans believe that GTA 6 could be
crossing the development Finish Line
soon hit the comment section right now
and let me know your predictions for the
game's release date as we dive into
these details Twitter account GTA 6 news
and leaks 2.0 uploaded screenshots from
multiple sources that have all claimed
to show the game off in a more complete
State when compared to last year's
massive League of in-development footage
the league contained more than 90 videos
and screenshots that were allegedly
released by a london-based hacker while
that early and unofficial look at GTA 6
left fans to believe that Rockstar's
next Sandbox game was still very early
in development the new report from GTA 6
news in lease 2.0 claims otherwise
linking to a forum post from Rockstar
Games Insider tez 2 multiple files for
Bank release beta and debug builds of
the game were discovered by the
individual it suggested that that these
files point to more feature complete
builds of GTA 6 which would include full
user interface functionality and a
roughly finished State for the game
while Rockstar works on polishing the
end result before release and ironing
out any bugs now I totally get it if you
want to change your prediction go ahead
edit your comment Rockstar has kept
quiet since the leaks went live with the
head of the parent company Take 2
Strauss zelnick saying that the
situation was quote terribly unfortunate
meanwhile GTA fans are attempting to use
the leaked footage to put together an
early estimation of GTA 6's open world
which looks to be as big or even bigger
than GTA 5's Los Santos but while you
wait for GTA 6 why not explore every
corner of cyberpunk 2077 for the first
time or again the game now has dlss 3
support as of today's patch so those
with supported Hardware on PC can enjoy
higher graphic settings and better
performance than previously possible and
by supported Hardware I'm talking about
if your computer has an Nvidia RTX 40
series card with dlss3 you can have
every setting and retrace option maxed
out for the best image quality according
to the press release with performance
being described as great cyberpunk 2077
also has a psycho mode Ray tracing
setting which adds raytrace Global
illumination letting sunlight Bounce
Around the World much more realistically
a setting not too many computers will be
able to handle and get this the update
is laying the groundwork for the
upcoming cyberpunk 2077 Ray tracing
overdrive mode update that will enhance
things even further other games promise
to be supported by dlss3 include a
plague tail Requiem stalker 2 and The
Witcher 3 wild Hunt with much more to
come what graphics card are you
currently rocking in your setup and do
you want to buy me a 40 series card let
me know hit me up hit me up does anybody
do this anymore